bonsoir je vous parle de la rue des
Entrepreneurs et je suis actuellement
avec un jeune et sympathique chef
d'entreprise qui est de ceux qui croi
que l'invention est la clé de la reprise
économique Jean firmain de la rue vous
venez d'ouvrir cette magnifique laverie
de cerveau à ne pourriez-vous nous
expliquer pourquoi
oui bien sûr c'est simple si vous voulez
les les souvenirs pèsent terriblement
lourd nous possédons tous en nous des
souvenirs qui nous hantent qui qui nous
paralysent j'ai pensé qu'il fallait
faire quelque chose et j'ai décidé
d'ouvrir le pressis le succès a été
immédiats pardon madame il y a une
marche fait attention
oui bien sûr vous n'avez pas idée du
nombre de gens qui nous supplient tous
les jours pour qu'on les débarrasse de
le mauvais souvenir oh là là ils sont
légion vraiment vraiment maintenant si
vous voulez bien entrer
merci la laverie de cerveau de Monsieur
de la rue est ouverte depuis le 3 mai
182 monsieur vous avez aussi des mauvais
souvenirs à oublier oui quand j'ai pissé
dans ma culotte à l'école en 8e à
Jacques Decour Jacques Decour ah
mademoiselle je cherche à oublier la
première fois que j'ai mangé un cassouet
parce
que vous permettez je vous IE et vous
mademoiselle la première fois
oui la première fois quoi première fois
qu'un type m'a possédé il m'a bien
possédé oh le Salou il m' sur toute la
ligne et évidemment vous cherchez à
l'oublier là oui elle cherche à
l'oublier
voilà mais tout le monde a des mauvais
souvenirs ainsi vous je suis certain
qu'il y en a au moins un qui vous obsède
non non oh en oui hein vous voyez lequel
me JEE de vous en parler non non non
mais écoutez pour vous prouver
l'efficacité de ma méthode nous allons
vous en débarrasser tout de suite
Sylvian oui
BL vous allez l'écrire sur cette feuille
non non mais crainte c'est complètement
confidentiel vous pensez bien
tenez
allez-y je ne regarde pas mais vous êtes
sûr que vous allez pas mettre dans une
de ces machines nous sommes pas des
sauvages oh là là Dieu merci il existe
d'autres technique n'ayez
crainte voilà voilà très bien regardez
hop hop hop hop et hop VZ prenez place
sur cette chaise
alors voilà je vous explique Sylviane va
vous souffler dans l'oreille droite et
votre mauvais souvenir sortira par
l'oreille
gauche
[Musique]
Sylvian et voilà terminé fini un deor
vous vous souvenez de quelque chose non
de rien
et bien maintenant si vous permettez je
vais vous lire votre mauvais souvenir et
nous en rirons
ensemble voilà j'ai écrasé trois enfants
un soir où j'étais ivre sur une petite
route du
Calvados
[Musique]